[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo vengo a marcarlos
los colombianos pasamos tres horas y
media al día pegados al celular
navegando en internet
y ese dato es similar en el mundo entero
y sólo tiende a aumentarse y aumentarse
y aumentarse
y eso es un problema es un problema
porque el mundo digital en su versión
actual es el espacio propicio para
fomentar todos nuestros vicios todos
nuestros sesgos para fomentar nuestra
violencia para fomentar en síntesis lo
peor
de la humanidad
lo que estamos viendo entonces es que
hay muchísima información cierta
información por todas partes pero no hay
comunicación nadie habla no hay diálogo
todos producimos información muy pocos
la consumimos y en medio de eso está
nuestro cerebro que se sobrecarga que no
es capaz de recibir todos estos
estímulos al mismo tiempo
en medio de eso surge la información
falsa claramente porque eso también está
pensado para explotar nueva habilidad
nuestro cerebro porque es un cerebro que
es muy manipulable como es manipulable
porque nosotros gusta compartir pero si
ustedes miran lo que nos gusta compartir
nos gusta compartir lo que nos emociona
lo que nos enfurece
lo que nos hace sentir bien pero ojo
esas emociones no se necesariamente
significan calidad cierto hecho muchas
veces uno comparte lo que le enfurece y
no tiene que ser cierto uno se emociona
con algo y no tiene que ser cierto
eso se une a que vivimos en burbujas
impenetrables ya sea de manera manual
porque ustedes van filtrando a sus redes
sociales a la gente que simplemente no
les cae bien que no quieren saber su tía
que está pensando cierto
porque está muy lejos o porque el
algoritmo también está diseñado para
explotar esa partecita del cerebro que
lo que quiere es encontrar algo que lo
emocione que lo moleste cierto sin
importar la fuente
esto se llama el sesgo de confirmación
cierto y es básicamente que nuestro
cerebro está construido para tener
ciertas debilidades porque queremos
creer ciertas cosas y somos por ende más
propensos a creer ciertas mentiras si
saben como contarnos las el problema y
es que el algoritmo y los anunciantes ya
también lo saben en internet entonces lo
que estamos viendo es la creación de un
montón de medios falsos diseñados para
explotar eso para engañarlos a cada uno
de ustedes para engañarme a mí porque
ellos saben por dónde pegarles ellos
saben que teoría de la conspiración les
encanta a ustedes no mientras cuando uno
escucha teoría de la conspiración uno
piensa a la tierra es plana no pero no
estas son teorías de la conspiración
muchísimo más elaboradas muchísimo más
finas y construidas exactamente para su
personalidad para lo que usted disfruta
para lo que usted no le gusta para sus
secretos más íntimos de lo que se gasta
esas tres horas y media en su celular
entonces lo que estamos viendo es que
nuestra sociedad está construida como ya
es una sociedad digital está construida
en una dinámica de ellos versus nosotros
porque nuestro cerebro también amase
maniqueísmo cierto y es
los poco ilustrados versos nosotros que
tenemos la razón los bobos que creen tal
cosa
versus nosotros que si somos escépticos
pero miren que eso como modelo de
sociedad es muy problemático y esto no
simplemente es un tema digital lo
estamos viendo que ya dio el salto a la
realidad y de manera trágica
mataron a una persona la lincharon acá
en bogotá la lincharon por una cadena de
whatsapp donde lo acusaban de ser un
secuestrador de niños falsamente por
cierto entonces todos estos vicios de
los que les vengo hablando cobraron una
vida
bru plastón lo dice muy bien y yo creo
que manera muy contundente en un libro
en el cual ella intenta entender qué es
lo que nos está pasando ella dice las
leyes de la naturaleza humana no
garantizan el triunfo de la razón
piensa en es un momentico la historia y
el internet nos han demostrado que ese
estereotipo es falso
entonces tiene sentido que si somos una
sociedad cada vez más digital la
sociedad real de carne y hueso muestre
sus sesgos estamos eligiendo mal estamos
eligiendo por miedo estamos aislando nos
estamos en tribus estamos en un
sectarismo violento y odiamos más
eso es un problema enorme
y esto hacia afuera pero a más que
quiero hablarles también un poquito a
nivel personal en cada uno de ustedes
porque qué es lo que pasa con las redes
sociales que las redes sociales nos
terminan estresando más porque ustedes
publican
yo estoy estresado por esto pero también
ven 40 tweets de gente que está
estresada por otra cosa y así el círculo
cierto se estresa no nos dejan dormir
las consultamos hasta largas horas de la
noche y luego dormimos mal nos vuelven
más celosos nos entristecen nos hacen
odiarnos a nosotros mismos porque como
así que hay gente perfecta y nosotros no
nos hacen olvidar a los otros porque
como así que alguien piensa eso cómo es
posible que alguien pueda pensar eso
nos dan ansiedad
despiertan y fomentan nuestra pasiva
agresividad estoy seguro que ustedes han
hecho algún comentario en alguna red
social bien pasivo agresivo que el
mensaje se entendió
seguramente tuvo muchos likes pero ven
el problema y también el peor de los
casos fomentan nuestra agresividad
agresividad
no sé si recuerdan una caricatura del
new yorker en el que hay dos perritos y
un perrito le dice al otro lo chévere de
internet es que nadie sabes que eres un
perro
yo lo que creo es que ya le dimos la
vuelta a eso sí y le hicimos una pequeña
adaptación y ahora decimos lo chévere
internet que nadie sabe que eres un
monstruo incluso hay algo peor ya la
gente si sabe que eres un monstruo pero
te lo celebra
supongo que es mal momento decirles que
me sigan en mis redes sociales
pero por todo esto es que dicen que
somos una generación perdida
la ch de que son ilustradora caleña lo
dice muy bien en esta viñeta ya dice yo
sin internet quién soy yo cuál es mi
propósito porque son ue lo dio a
borondongo
esa es la crisis en la que estamos pero
yo creo que es una crisis falsa por dos
motivos primero porque no somos sólo
nosotros los millennials y este tipo de
mecanismos que existen en internet
ofertan afectan a todos los usuarios de
internet dependientemente de la edad
segundo porque la realidad y eso lo que
yo vengo a proponerles ustedes no es que
seamos una generación perdida
simplemente somos una generación
distraída
la buena noticia es que con eso se puede
trabajar
también lo hice mejor cuál será la clave
del wifi para conectarse con el universo
entonces yo hoy vengo a contarles 5 tips
para recuperar internet y no bloquearse
en el intento un poquito esto produce de
eso viene del trabajo que yo he podido
venir haciendo con unos equipos
maravillosos en el espectador que hemos
creado la puya las igualdad la pues
verdad érase una vez en colombia la red
social en últimas lo que usted si
ustedes miran cada uno de estos
proyectos tienen en común una cosa y es
queremos en medio del ruido en medio de
la confusión en medio de todos estos
sesgos tener una voz que la gente quiera
escuchar entonces vengo a contarles unas
cinco lecciones que pueden sacar de acá
que de pronto ustedes independientemente
de cuál sea su proyecto
independientemente si simplemente
quieren sobrevivir en el mundo digital
pueden aplicar primero necesitamos una
mejor polarización porque eso es lo otro
la gente le teme a la polarización
cierto es como o no pero no vea una de
las maravillas de internet que le obliga
a la gente a tomar partido no solamente
eso sino que pueden ser vehementes lo
que les gusta cierto lo que necesitamos
entonces es tener mejor polarización a
qué se refiere de eso tener
investigaciones rigurosas tener
discusiones mucho más complejas tener
aportes que le digan algo a la gente
christopher hitchens tiene una fase
me encanta él dice yo nunca soy ofensivo
espero por accidente necesitamos mejores
ofensas porque la ofensa cuando va
contra los sagrados y los sagrados de un
mecanismo de opresión es un excelente
mecanismo de resistencia de construir
sociedad si no lo primero es no le teman
a la polarización pero si busquen una
mejor polarización y eso está ligado a
lo segundo tenemos que ser honestos y
esto tiene un par de capas donde la
primera capa es como ustedes se
presentan en internet este cuento de que
todos somos influenciadores
nos tiene con un lenguaje terrible
abandonen ese lenguaje ante el hashtag
bendecida afortunada
por favor
sean sinceros la vida es trágica la vida
es difícil la vida es dura cuenten lo
que dejen el discurso de gente estar
hablándole a una audiencia no cuenten
ustedes porque están pensando lo que
están pensando porque están frustrados
si ustedes empiezan a cambiar ese
contenido en sus redes empezamos a
cambiar todo el discurso y empezamos
también a quitarnos los disfraces pero
es una necesidad también está ligada con
unas preguntas internas al momento de
ustedes ya entrar a las redes y yo les
tengo acá tres preguntas que les sugiero
la primera es porque estoy diciendo esto
lo estoy diciendo porque quiero
reconocimiento porque quiero que la
gente que piensa como yo me felicite o
porque en verdad tengo que decirlo por
otro motivo porque le voy a dar eco a
esto porque de pronto me está prendiendo
algo en el cerebro que me gusta en este
cerebro que venimos hablando
porque vale la pena porque será que
estoy hablando la mitad de mi familia y
6 será que es que son bowls para que es
que no entienden para qué es que están
pensando cosas locas o será que es que
más bien yo no puedo ponerme en sus
zapatos y no pueden tener su perspectiva
introduzcan esas prácticas y eso es lo
mismo que nosotros hacemos en nuestros
productos semana semana tercero una
dieta firme estricta ya que los
influenciadores también son fitness
cierto de confrontación y escepticismo
primero confrontación rompan el
algoritmo si el algoritmo sólo les
muestra gente que piensa como ustedes
vayan a buscar gente que no piensa como
ustedes introduzcan medios con los
cuales ustedes no estén de acuerdo
lean columnas de opinión que desde la
primera frase los empiecen a poner
furiosos enfrenten esa rabia y
pregúntense qué es lo que está pasando
acá tienen una responsabilidad de
comerse sus vegetales y los vegetales
digitales es leer lo que no quiere leer
lo que nos saca de la zona de confort y
el escepticismo está ligado a la
cuestión en todo cuestión en si esta
noticia que ustedes están compartiendo
con tanta emoción no será que la están
compartiendo porque quieren creer que es
verdad no porque sea verdad
y el cuarto es aprovechar la distracción
si nos encantan los memes y nos encanta
tener 40 vídeos abiertos y nos encantan
los vídeos de perritos loquitos
disfrazados de halloween verdad listo
que de ahí podemos utilizar hagan
productos simples hagan productos con
memes hagan productos con un lenguaje
que les llegue un montón de gente
el formato no es lo que importa lo que
importa es el fondo que usted le pone el
formato si estamos en la era de la
distracción pero ustedes pueden hablar
el lenguaje luego manejan día a día
encuentren la manera de hacerlo
hararé tiene una frase buenísima y es en
el mundo inundado de información
irrelevante la claridad es poder busquen
la claridad busquen ser útil aporten
contenido útil para la gente en medio de
este ruido y con lo que los quiero dejar
es la quinta sugerencia de 10 a
marquense con propósito miren que cada
uno de los proyectos en los que yo estoy
surgen de una frustración surgen de un
descontento surgen de un problema con el
mundo real sí pero lo que uno puede es
dejar que ese sí mismo lo estanque o
hacer el ejercicio de listo yo como le
puedo dar la vuelta a esto creen a pesar
de todo cree en cosas háganle equivoquen
se fracasen rotundamente
pero tenés el permiso de ser más que lo
que la sociedad nos ha dicho que podemos
ser en el mundo digital para
experimentos sólo quiero una frase que
me parece fascinante de una serie de
eventos desafortunados y dice si
esperamos hasta que estemos listos y
aquí yo agrego si esperamos hasta que
internet sea un lugar mágico ideal en el
cual no nos odiamos los unos a los otros
estaremos esperando el resto de nuestras
vidas
no esperen
háganles quiero ver lo que van a crear
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]